what are a few of the current and
biggest unsolved challenges in the field
of commercial space travel I think the
biggest one is expensive but I thought
that's the whole point of SpaceX trying
to drop the price so they haven't
dropped it enough is what you're saying
not remotely so oh if you want to talk
about you know making it accessible to
not just governments or billionaires um
we got a ways to go you're going to
still need to bring consumables with you
it's going to require mass and you need
a big rocket but you also need that
rocket to not be crazy expensive right
right and so that's that sort of balance
that kind of needs to happen to make
that work I want you to be quantitative
so how many years from now 10 years 20
years where a family can save up we
going to get Disney World or we going to
go to space I think it's 20 20 years
maybe 15 but probably 20 that's really
close that's very encouraging